estaban los cálculos de todos los
analistas que el vencedor de estas
elecciones parlamentarias e iraquíes del
pasado domingo volvería a ser el clérigo
populista chiíta múqtada a saber que ya
había salido vencedor en el 2018 lo que
pocos esperaban era que fuera tener una
votación tan abultada de tener 54
escaños en el parlamento ahora tendrá al
menos 73 pero lo más inesperado de estas
elecciones ha sido el derrumbe de las
agrupaciones políticas cercanas a las
milicias cercanas a irán especialmente
la coalición al fatá que había salido
segunda las elecciones pasadas y obtuvo
48 escaños en aquel momento ahora no
obtendría ni siquiera 18 lo que ha
llevado a que su líder y también
comandante de las milicias vader haya
asegurado que el resultado de estas
elecciones eran fabricados y que ellos
iban a reclamar porque no tendría que
ser así lo mismo hizo el otro político
de otra agrupación
militar milicianas el canal de cativá
hezbollah que habían creado un grupo
político para estas elecciones y que
obtuvo muy pocos votos también llamó a
estas elecciones de fraude por lo que
veremos en las próximas semanas una gran
contienda que podría escalar a mayores
depende hasta donde quieran llevarlos
estas milicias que tienen armas por
fuera del control del estado